I got a question for everybody
these single white liberal women who are
in their mid to late 30s Milano's like
I'm 36 I'm going to be 37 soon 31. these
these what do they call them affluent
white female liberals Catwoman they have
no kids what are they going to do when
they're 60 70 years old they have no
family to take care of them when they
can no longer work what are they going
to do
they're gonna be depressed they're gonna
have a lot of cats we're already saying
it I mean they're going to be on a lot
of drugs how are they going to get those
drugs big Pharma how are they going how
why would you're saying big farm is
going to be like lady here's some free
drugs no no they're gonna of course uh
yeah have only fans that can afford it
some 70 year olds may find an audience
but overwhelmingly it's not going to
happen true so my question is how will
they get those drugs
I don't know come on Ubi maybe they're
going to vote for what
they're going to vote for oh they're
going to vote Democrat regardless people
who don't have families yeah to support
them will vote for the state the state
correct yeah they are communism baby
yeah that's true they already do
atheists single single atheist people
obviously mostly vote Democrat but
single single women unmarried women
they're big voter block and they were
very significant for these midterms as
well they made a major difference yeah
if you look at from the 2018 midterms to
this midterms we didn't gain at all with
unmarried women
it's not just about the women though
it's it's about the men as well
but you know I'm just wondering seeing
all of these people who are not having
families and are advocating for not
having families right when they're in
their 70s in their retirement age
there's going to be an elderly antifa
riots demanding more money yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's why I have too there's
going to be a lot of broken hips
seriously I'm trying to have 10 kids
trying to have a football I want seven
football I want a basketball team hey
I've been saying that for years
to Luke I mean why not right you better
get started I'm working on it yeah I
gotta get started too yeah yeah it's
crazy out there yeah crazy world man
then you gotta Shield those kids against
the reality and that's that's the they
will be like little Jedis like everyone
that comes into my life I teach them how
to shoot I teach them how to defend
themselves I teach them I hand to hand
combat uh I don't care if you're a woman
I don't care if you're a friend I keep
motivating everyone here like let's do
the kickboxing let's kick some butt
that's great uh so I mean that's just me
around me my kids are going to be around
that so they're going to be raised to
know how to handle a firearm as well my
kids gonna be menacist I can tell you
that right now people think I'm bad
I'd say homeschool your kids yes keep
them away from this uh Welk degeneracy
and stuff like that yes it's scary out
there but there's more than just that
there's you how you know you're getting
good sound medical advice you got to
find a good doctor especially those kids
growing up you got to make sure you're
getting real food you're not going to
pump their brains full of fluoride I
love how they have the nursery water
with extra fluoride in it but then you
can simply Google search and it's like
there's there's recommendation from
um pediatric doctors and stuff like
don't give your babies fluoride why do
they sell that at the grocery store oh
yeah we interviewed doctor after doctor
till we found like the right place when
we moved down here because you can't
trust doctor we got kicked out of
practices for not doing certain things
they wanted us to do when they wanted us
to do it in New York when we're still
there well it's it's simple you you go
to a doctor you ask them basic questions
about your health and if they can't
answer basic questions then you need to
find a good doctor yeah and a lot of
doctors these days I feel like I just go
there and and they hardly look at me
they're just looking at a computer and
checking off like check marks they just
throw pills at you yeah I'm like I
didn't come here for this yeah anyway
women that's why you know they they
always recommend anything is wrong with
a woman they always tell them birth
control right yeah
[Music]
so like some doctors that will be honest
with you and give you like holistic
doctors or you have to go to like some
natural doctors but most of these
mainstream daughters that they're just
throwing the worst thing at you they'll
do it for everything like depression
everything skin everything anything they
possibly birth control has so many
negative side effects so many things
that mess up mess up your thyroid mess
up your whole reproductive system uh it
is absolutely one of the most
destructive medicines out there that
people aren't warned they're they aren't
told hey this is going to create
long-term damages or it could even lead
to you having the wrong partner since
your your pheromones and your smells are
going to be off yeah and then once
you're off of them you're gonna not be
attracted to the person you're with so
it's just crazy but that's what the
experts are telling them though we're in
like a failure of experts my last doctor
in New York I I get anxiety real bad
throughout you know whatever uh and my
last time I had real bad anxiety I went
to the doctor I'm looking to see what we
could do so I'm hoping I would hear like
we gotta work on that diet and you know
eat better you can get some exercise she
literally told me to get the the vaccine
and I was like like why she was like
well help with your fear I'm like well I
don't have fear of that like my anxiety
is like with like money kids you know
life stuff like that and uh that's what
that was her first response what I never
saw her again I was like I'm out well I
would have told her off I would have
been like well are you crazy
what are you doing here I was so shocked
I just left I was like I can't believe
it was real what's the right answer like
therapy the doctor's saying like I
recommend you sit down with a therapist
that would be better yeah you know but
like honestly I thought we were gonna
have like a talk I I wanted to have my
heart looked at I I I'm crazy sometimes
I'm like maybe something's wrong
cardiogram and that was her that's how
she came to me yeah if someone's dealing
with anxiety you're like okay what are
you eating how's your sleep are you
exercising right uh how is your gut
let's do a gut test let's see let's
let's do a full test on your your you
know levels of of uh you know hormones
in your body Let's test it out let's see
if this is an imbalance let's see if
this is just mental let's let's figure
out let's diagnose the problem
look I'm I'm not a doctor so make sure
you talk to a doctor about what's right
for you but I just I feel like whenever
I meet someone and they say something
like I'm suffering from these conditions
the first thing I think is what are you
eating yeah oh it's so true is it yeah
and I feel like a lot of these people
like there was a commercial I was
watching and it's like suffering from
heartburn and it's just a guy going like
and it's like take this pill and it says
I'm eating pizza and I'm like dude if
you're eating the pizza and it's
screwing you up stop eating the pizza
man no but no we could just take a pill
and it's gonna be fine do you drink a
lot of coffee yes do you drink it first
thing in the morning without anything uh
yes okay stop doing that okay so you are
my doctor stop doing that that's what I
do every day for breakfast yeah and he's
fine that's my brain
I don't know if it's fine uh but that's
the San Francisco sorry uh what is going
on we'll have a private talk later I
talk about this all the time I've been
looking at the studies I I literally uh
do this on my own like members area
where I diagnose and I go into the
studies and I talk about this but that's
but that's one thing but I love having
these conversations especially with like
Dr Drew when he was here uh but but stop
doing that immediately recommend we'll
talk later taking a pause drinking
drinking water and that yeah not medical
advice I'm not a medical doctor not here
here giving you however medical advice
uh but uh we'll talk privately because I
don't want to get into two more every
day of yourself every day I wake up
and uh recently I've been doing brewed
coffee like like you know your typical
ground Brew I usually do cold brew I
love cold brew it tastes so much better
yeah and uh I'll do uh heavy cream and
coffee and that's what I have and then
for a while I talked about this I was
doing eggs and bacon but recently I just
been not having breakfast so I just just
straight coffee with coffee and cream
that's it I never have coffee in my life
I've ever tried it wow what never tried
coffee is it why
I'm a super taster yeah so I probably
couldn't I probably wouldn't be able to
handle coffee how do you know you're a
super taster oh you you just yo you have
less taste buds or more taste buds
whatever I think yeah yeah more taste
sometimes have more taste buds and we're
just very sensitive for like bitter
things so I don't eat anything spicy
like nothing spicy if chicken is too
spicy I won't eat it I eat like a child
but I drink so much water that it is I
don't want to get into too much personal
health stuff for for you guys but
there's a reason you know someone here
has gut issues
um and the best thing to do is to at
least wait at least an hour and a half
uh because of this uh stress issues uh I
have stomach ulcers is that what you're
talking about no oh no I'm talking about
someone else uh we'll talk about the
privately maybe yeah someone here
um the best thing to do is start with
either kefir no I'm not not talking
about myself I'm talking about someone
else here sitting here
my anxiety in my gut yeah
not even you oh no but but uh you you
should wait at least an hour and a half
uh be because of uh your hormones to
take coffee and to not feel sluggish
during the middle of the day and you
should always try to get at least uh
kefir or yogurt in your stomach before
taking something as heavy and as acidic
as coffee into your system so uh
prolonged coffee use uh my own not not
medical advice this is just what I do
and I've seen uh important developments
and changes in my uh feelings and my gut
after implementing this myself it might
work for you it might not uh you might
be allergic to kefir who knows so
everybody's careful everybody's
different the best advice I give people
especially when it comes to a lot of
this stuff is is no one is no one and
nothing is exactly right for everybody
you could be allergic to something that
works for me but it could be horrible
for you so you got to do your own
homework you got to do your own research
and more than ever you have to be
vigilant more than ever obesity rates
are going up out our calorie intake
hasn't changed what's going on here
something is corrupt something's really
horrible something really nefarious is
happening right now with People's Health
being deliberately destroyed you got to
be on top of it more than ever that's
what I do for myself and we could talk
and maybe even do like a little video
between me and you if you're open to it
oh yeah and I'll put it on my members
area Shaman for 10 years and gave up
Western medicine for a long time uh but
like I I uh I've done the thing for a
while and I had I did see differences
where I would wake up and just drink um
warm water with lemon and nothing else
Ginger is pretty good too oh Ginger too
mastic gum is also really good uh
colostrum is also really good especially
if you have good issues but again again
you could be allergic to those things
and do your own homework and it might
hurt you depending on your gut level I
cut out a lot of most carbs years ago
and lost like 40 or 50 pounds yeah and
that my brain just got different I slept
better thought better I was way better
at everything this is this is it bro you
know a year ago I cut out carbs and uh
looking great now looking a lot better
not that you didn't before but you lost
a lot of weight yeah I lost uh it was
crazy too because I was skating all the
time I was skating like every day but I
still weighed 200 pounds and and then
one day we got covered we got treated
for it and then like a few days later I
was eating salami with cheese and then I
was like you know I didn't need any
sugar today I feel great I just didn't
eat it and people were saying that
you're gonna get keto flu from not
having any sugar I never experienced
anything yeah no no no headache nothing
just all of a sudden within like within
the first month I dropped 10 pounds and
then over the course of the next couple
of months I dropped another 20 pounds do
y'all drink coffee like every day oh I
drink coffee a lot bro I got two young
kids it's hard uh I will say that like
that part makes it hard they wake up at
night I'm up super early and I'm up at
night you know writing late into the
hours but uh yeah coffee so yeah so yeah
like
no that's so interesting to me because I
don't drink anything like that but I'm
super energetic it's a part of my ritual
like when I'm I get the kids down I can
work for a nap or bring them to school
and I can make a cup of coffee and
that's how I kind of get into work mode
does this actually keep you up I heard
sometimes I can have the opposite effect
I don't think it even works on me
anymore so you're just trying to do the
tradition
if you drink coffee around like if you
normally go to bed at like 11 you drink
coffee around seven you won't be
attacked you won't be tired because it
blocks The receptors I think what
melatonin or something that's right yeah
you shouldn't be taking it uh but if you
if you drink it so people who think it
wakes them up in the morning it really
doesn't caffeine does have enough uh
well I'm not gonna know everything about
caffeine but it does have very it's a
stimulant so it's it's it increases
muscle endurance it tightens your blood
vessels if you if you stop drinking
coffee you'll get migraines because it
relax it relaxes your blood vessels and
then you get a more pressure and then
your head starts to Robin and there's
also a correlation there's also a very
interesting correlation with uh our
progression as Society with the
invention of coffee and people taking
coffee becoming more productive working
a lot harder and smarter and a lot of
people attribute coffee to Modern
civilization growing as fast and as vast
as it is now so I mean coffee smells
good you ever just open up fresh ground
coffee it smells terrible to me that's
why I've never tried it because of the
smell
it's pretty much illegalized cocaine
it does yeah take a look at the effects
of caffeine and cocaine the only
difference with with caffeine it's like
little bits in your drink with cocaine
it's like on the street in higher doses
but you they sell powdered caffeine and
it is it is crazy it has very similar uh
psychological and physiological effects
to cocaine yeah I'm good I got I got
enough energy I think I took some of
that I'll lose my mind this is something
this isn't really funny if you look up
caffeine powder on Amazon I don't know
if this is true but I was told that you
know Amazon does frequently bought with
it's like lidocaine and caffeine are
frequently bought together yeah so like
you do you know you know okay what
people yeah
what yeah it's like it's it's like a
it's like a yeah people are sniffing
coffee
no no pick caffeine powder let's meet
significant they're just I don't know
exactly what they're doing DIY are they
snorting it like
I don't know I wouldn't be surprised I
recommend against it because you get
hurt wait until you learn about the
coffee enemas uh you can find out oh no
look uncensored.com hey
[Laughter]
call me crazy do your research now on
coffee enemas be prepared to surprise
and I'll see you for that conversation
on Lucas it sounds like China what is it
no no coffee animals I'm I'm dead ass
I'm being real I'm being honest here
that ass cause you're putting coffee up
your butt yes
that was the pun intended humans are
weird bro yeah for real like good or all
that I am you never see like a lion
shoving coffee beans up its ass never
unless I don't know maybe you do I don't
know when I was outside your store when
I was a little kid we wanted a field
trip to the zoo and we were looking at
the baboons and it was like this the
enclosure was way down and then one of
the baboons just shoved his thumb right
up his ass and then pulled something out
and then all the kids ran over and
started screaming and hollering the
teacher was like what's going on and she
went oh get away kids get because the he
was going to town I don't know what he
was doing the monkeys are weird man
that's what I'm saying you said humans
are weird I'm like I don't know monkeys
are pretty weird too he knows what
they're on about he was the weird stuff
bro I'm sorry yeah well yeah I I guess
in this instance you're talking about
Luke because he's putting coffee with
his butt but you know let's read some
super chats wait wait before the Super
Chat Tim are you not on the yay 24 train
I'm not on the a24 train are you guys I
I don't I don't know because me I am
like a Bible thumping hardcore Christian
so when he says like the thing the thing
that irritated me about the Alex Jones
interview but the obviously the age guy
comments the only thing is because he
said some of the most beautiful things
I've ever heard in the interview and it
got the water got muddied because of
that one comment and people missed like
the prayer he read was so beautiful he's
saying Yeshua he's saying Yahweh I'm not
you're not supposed to say Yahweh but he
he's saying like the most beautiful
thing in fact he got overlooked but what
he says things like things to be based
on Christianity I mean that's already
how this country should be and it's so
based I love it thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time